cómo
por favor
buenas noches a todos pero me hablarles
un poquito de las tres de la forma de
cómo conseguir el éxito por unos lastres
que me han dado a mí la posibilidad de
estar en donde me ha tocado estar en la
selección la américa en diferentes
equipos monterrey atlante veracruz tecos
y no creo que haya otra forma y mucha
gente me pregunta después que si hay más
cosas yo creo que lo principal es
liderazgo trabajo en equipo y motivación
y mucha gente y dónde quedó la
estrategia y cómo parar un equipo como
hacer un balón parado pues conlleva a
que estemos concentrados en el trabajo
en equipo yo vengo de una familia como
yo creo que mucha gente en méxico la
mayoría de la gente en méxico de la
familia clase media donde hay que luchar
le hay que salir para salir adelante hay
que estar decididos y yo me pusiera una
meta en mi cabeza yo quería ser
futbolista y estaba motivado por ser
futbolista en mi proceso estudiando pues
me senté con mi madre con mi abuela y
les dije que eran las que llevaban la
casa
apoyo en medio quiero ser futbolista
pero si a los 20 años yo no he debutado
en primera división pues me voy antes
era más difícil que ahora porque hoy las
fuerzas básicas y bases de la escuelita
desde los 13 años ahí te sigues en un
equipo y se te puede dar o no la
oportunidad porque también después la
capacidad nosotros nos jugamos en el
llano lo que llamamos jugar en la
magdalena mixuca donde ahora está el
foro sol donde pasan todos ahí las
canchas de esas de tierra hay jugábamos
y teníamos que tener un poquito la
suerte de que alguien nos viera
y no hay esta parte que de repente hice
nada seguro fue el recomendado yo
conmigo si hay muchos recomendados y
llegan hasta donde está la rayita de la
cancha ahí llega su recomendación
después para adentro les digo ahí vienen
lo que es tu motivación tus ganas de ser
y tu capacidad si las tienes bienvenido
y demuestra las porque tú el que te
empujó te empujó hasta aquí para que
adentro tienes 11 compañeros o 10
compañeros y tú para demostrar que puede
ser futbolista no afortunadamente antes
de los 20 años bien o 20 años debuta en
primera división y de ahí hasta la fecha
sigo en el fútbol metido tratando de
cada día ser mejor tratando de lograr
éxitos que siempre he dicho que los
éxitos que unos logran es el
convencimiento del trabajo en equipo y
eso obviamente me hace ser el líder del
grupo o yo siempre digo los muchachos
son los que tienen el éxito
diarra y me arrastran en su éxito pero
bueno solamente necesito ser su líder
para que me crean para que estén
convencidos con lo que yo les digo es lo
mejor con lo que yo hago lo que yo
trabajo lo que yo
plasmó en mi cabeza en las noches de
estar haciendo estrategias están
revisando a los rivales pues voy se los
digo a ver muchos de esos momentos de
hacer esto vamos a trabajar sobre esto
sobre esta base es la alineación es la
formación y vamos a darle para adelante
y después buenos en las pláticas antes
previas a los partidos hay un poquito de
motivación si yo le digo al jugador tú
eres el mejor del mundo y no hay nadie
mejor que tú y messi al lado de ti pues
no existe y si yo no lo convenzo porque
trabajo nueva así está todo eso está
todo a dar que me dije que soy el mejor
del mundo pero ahora qué hago dentro de
la cancha no y bueno hay que trabajar
para que el muchacho crea que lo que
estamos haciendo es lo mejor y que esté
convencido de que si sales yendo o
tratando de ser el mejor bueno me topado
con muchos caminos con muchas cosas que
por supuesto me hacen ser cada día más
líder no uno dice
líder es el líder de fútbol del
entrenador de ser fácil pues no es tan
fácil porque a veces el entrenador nos
cobra muchísimo menos que los jugadores
entonces hay que convencerlos de que
tiene que jugar y yo voy
tú tienes que hacer esto y esto y esto y
de repente me puede decir oye por qué me
dices eso si yo como más que tú hago las
cosas me contrataron tengo más años de
contrato que tú y tú vienes a decirme
que es lo mejor bueno pues es parte de
tratar de mostrarle por qué uno es líder
porque uno tiene la condición de
trabajar y hacer que trabajen como tú
quieres que trabajen después por
supuesto vienen los resultados las cosas
salen pueden salir bien o mal dentro de
una cancha porque es un deporte es un
juego al fin de cuentas también el rival
cuenta también rival es un tipo que está
en un equipo que está preparado entonces
hay que tratar de convencernos de hacer
todas las cosas que nos han dado y no
seguir andando mientras anunciamos yendo
bien esta posibilidad entonces
comunicarle a ustedes que si no hay
trabajo en equipo no existe sino de
trabajo en equipo en cualquier área
donde se trabaja con grupos y en mi caso
es muy chistoso no porque nosotros
nosotros centramos un día antes de los
partidos y normalmente te concentras con
el tipo que disfrutas tu puesto
los defensas que estamos con las
defensas los delanteros con los
delanteros
los porteros los dos porteros están
juntos en la misma habitación y diría
uno como le quitó el puesto este si ese
es el titular y es mi compañero y
resulta que es mi amigo bueno eso es
trabajo en equipo porque los dos tienen
una sinergia bastante fuerte y yo tengo
que tratar de que él vea que estoy
trabajando muy fuerte porque quiero su
lugar porque quiero su lugar a la buena
porque quiero competir con él para poder
desplazarlo si él no pone atención o si
él no hace lo que le piden entonces eso
es lo que tenemos convencido tenemos un
equipo donde lo primero que digo es acá
vale quejarse
vale decir esto no me gusta aquello no
me gusta pero pararse nunca
nunca la condición de actitud
no es tan negociable todos fueron su
actitud todos tenemos determinación y
después pues yo soy el que decido
quiénes juegan y tengo 25 jugadores y
nada más puedo llevar 18 cada partido y
nada más juegan 11 y después 3 cambios
entonces es una cosa que es difícil si
no tienes ese liderazgo si el jugador no
cree en tu liderazgo y si tú no haces
ese trabajo en equipo que eres justo con
los muchachos el que anda bien juega el
que es pues no anduvo una semana bien lo
expulsaron por una reclamación por una
cosa injustificada dentro del grupo que
es una patada un golpe tonto un
reclamarle al árbitro pues el que está
atrás entra porque entonces no generó
esta competencia deportiva que un grupo
debe tener para crecer y afortunadamente
me ha tocado tomar grupos difíciles
difíciles del sentido de
de este de esta exigencia que tiene este
club en américa exigen todo hay que
ganar títulos si pierdes un partido el
técnico es tan bueno tan malo como su
último resultado no afortunadamente un
último resultado fue bueno pero si era
hemos perdido a no ya es un malo
acabamos de ganar el campeonato pero ya
perdiste el domingo pasado no ya no es
tan bueno que hay que correrlo y así es
nuestro nuestro trabajo entonces tenemos
que demostrarle a la gente que el que
trabajamos con ella que somos líderes
dentro de este grupo tengo que tener
líderes y tengo que hacerlo bien que
ellos sean el ejemplo a sus compañeros
para que tengamos todos la misma idea y
por supuesto la exigencia en la cancha
sea una sola no yo puedo gritar de la
raya de la cancha y ves que no soy en
los estadios están llenos pero para eso
tengo líderes que transmiten dentro de
la cancha lo que uno quiere y bueno pues
con eso tengo pláticas de repente
especial es decir a ver yo del instituto
que sea con su trabajo el mejor que no
se queje que no ponga la circunstancia
de decir me hoy no hoy estamos cansados
pero si están cansados que también
tengan la personalidad
decirme es que el grupo está cansado y
necesitamos por lo menos hoy bajarle un
poquito al entrenamiento para estar
listos para el partido entonces todas
estas cosas que los líderes tienen que
tener dentro de un grupo no para que
pueda ser transmitido por la cabeza que
en este caso me tocó ser a mí y poder
transmitir a un grupo en un trabajo en
equipo conseguir la victoria tus son
series de cosas que realmente nos hacen
entender que el fútbol es el fútbol es
muy complejo no deja contento a nadie es
nuestro trabajo a diferencia de muchos
de ustedes está constantemente en la
exigencia en yo creo que ningún trabajo
de ustedes hay 30 mil gentes gritando a
quién poner a quien sacar cómo jugar no
ya te estás equivocando y no es que tú
no estás gol y pone al cepillo y ahí voy
volcar por el cepillo pongo el cepillo y
fallo el cepillo te dije que no pongas
al cepillo y entonces es difícil no
porque hay 30.000 entrenadores y nuestra
chamba está constantemente siendo
valorada
y a lo mejor usted es de repente puente
en una equivocación y decir bueno esta
semana no me fue bien no logramos tener
el mejor control del trabajo pero si en
las 100 semanas de semana no me fue bien
esta semana pasada que fue clave que
tenía dos partidos muy importantes no sé
si no me ha venido bien seguiré
trabajando es así tan demandante la
posición de un entrenador que está en un
equipo donde la exigencia es ganar ganar
ganar y no no tiene nada no nosotros
cerramos el campeonato y previo a ese
campeonato perdemos un partido
importante de la copa contra un equipo
de ascenso en penales pues por supuesto
alguien está en la oficina del dueño del
equipo y ya sabrán todo lo que me dijo y
tú te traje porque eres el responsable
porque tienes que ganar yo sí y
compromiso es ganar y tenemos que ganar
y el título lo tenemos que traer y yo me
comprometo y por supuesto si te
comprometes tienes que tratar de hacerlo
no tratar porque reitero todo tiene
tiene una circunstancia y se puede dar o
no se puede dar pero por lo menos en el
intento y en hacer las cosas lo mejor
posible se tienen que ver
los trabajos bueno ganamos el título
afortunadamente pues esto dentro del
vestidor está feliz me abrazan mis
felicidades ya está la 3 aquí pero
empieza a trabajar porque ya quiero la
14 y yo calculo pero dejamos de cantar
déjame disfrutarla pero bueno esta es la
exigencia que tiene uno como entrenador
de un equipo tan exigente y bueno ni
hablar cuando fuimos con la selección no
vine al haciendo las cosas muy bien con
la con el américa acá vamos a ser
campeones también en un torneo donde
íbamos súper líderes y todo iba todo era
felicidad y de repente se atraviesa la
selección con la bronca de que no se iba
a calificar y me dicen pues vas a la
selección a tratar de traer el boleto al
mundial y todos los medios me decían por
qué tomar la selección ahorita porque no
esperas el siguiente proceso porque
seguramente por lo que has hecho te lo
van a tener que dar y arriesgas todo lo
que has hecho a dos partidos
y ustedes y siempre como siempre ha sido
no pues porque si no lo tomo ahorita a
lo mejor mañana no viene y yo lo que
quiero es eso entonces no me importa si
tengo que arriesgar tanto mi trabajo
toda mi carrera de entrenador por dos
partidos porque me tengo confianza y
porque tengo la capacidad de lograrlo y
después de bueno que lo conseguimos sí
ya cuando iba ahí vamos a la nueva
zelanda era todo a ver si lo logran ni
habérselo y cuando trajimos el 93 92 que
quedamos en un partido global estaba
bien fácil
a pan comido era cualquier hablaría y
esa es la bronca de esta chamba no de
repente de hacer todas estas cosas que a
veces son tan gratificantes pero también
se son demandantes no yo de repente a mi
familia les digo es que están los
momentos malos hay que disfrutarlos
porque esperemos que sean muy poquitos y
disfrutar un poquito decir bueno se nos
fue mal y te vamos a trabajar mejor y
vamos a hacer las cosas mejor para poder
continuar en esta chamba no y
afortunadamente si han sido malos en los
cuales he aprendido bastante para poder
seguir creciendo y poder empezar me tocó
tomar un equipo como veracruz pues
estaba pronosticando de descender pero
yo yo yo las puedo todos decirlo salvo y
si los albos y pues no lo salvé y
desafortunadamente eso marca tu carrera
porque es un descenso
y yo decía bueno pues ahí entendí que no
todo es atacar que no todo esto está si
puedo y si está un siglo pero también
hay que saber cómo tomar las cosas cómo
concentrarse en lo que tienes que hacer
cómo ir evolucionando porque hoy en día
la palabra evolución tiene que ser
prácticamente meterte en tu cabeza
porque hoy en día es muy bueno pero si
no evolucionas te pasan o nunca nos
hablamos a lo mejor como de ciertas
trató la maestra que tenemos 50 años y
pareciera que son muy viejos y si ves la
rapidez de la tecnología es claro a mí
me tocó el teléfono de rueditas y le
dábamos vuelta y tratar tratar a jobs
guayana maldices marca la fulana styps
marca la xunta no te contestan sus
ilustres en la bolsa y nosotros que trae
yo recuerdo en la casa ustedes contrario
les quitó ser un un teléfono pues que
agarramos y con un cordón como de 10
metros para cambiar para allá y para
allá por todos lados entonces esa
evolución la tenemos que tener también
nosotros y esa evolución en el trabajar
en el equipo
y tener motivación porque yo me levanto
todas las mañanas y digo porque tengo
que hacer yo respetando a todas las
profesiones que hay aquí que son muy
buenas y que soy orgulloso padre anáhuac
porque mi hija se recibió en esta
universidad entonces yo digo cada día
gracias a dios que soy una persona que
trabaja en lo que me gusta para mí la
profesión del futbolista
hoy director técnico es la más bonita
del mundo hago lo que me gusta pues me
critican o no pero me conoce la gente y
además me pagan y me pagan muy bien y
lavalle digo padre no que la gente pueda
hacer eso y por supuesto creo que todos
los que nos recibimos de alguna de
alguna otra profesión pues necesitamos
ahí porque nos gusta entonces cuando nos
levantamos todas las mañanas yo todas
las medias tengo la motivación decir hoy
estoy listo para seguir haciendo lo que
me gusta
porque me gusta hacerlo si no me sale
bien y me corren
mañana otra porque si después tengo que
hacer otra chamba que no me gusta por
obligación porque tengo que seguir
manteniendo a la familia ahí es donde yo
creo que la gente empieza a perder la
motivación entonces todas las mañanas
levántense con salud es lo principal que
podemos pedir salud porque puedes
decirnos a qué pedirle a dios si hay que
pedirle a dios salud o alcohol que por
el que crean porque pues hay que poner
nosotros yo me siento eleva diosa ya
tengo salud sobre darle de comer pues
tampoco a entonces mi mi éxito gracias a
lo que he trabajado es primero
motivación yo reitero todo los días me
levanto con muchas ganas de hacer cada
día lo que me gusta hacer segundo llegó
a trabajar en un equipo donde las cosas
van hacemos como un autor muchos lo han
dicho como una familia y mi mujer me
dice si te casas con el fútbol y tienes
25 hijos y todavía estás con ellos bueno
sí sí la verdad es en mi caso porque
estoy vivo las 24 horas del día pensando
en lo que tengo que hacer y a pesar de
que mi familia sacrifica mucho está
conmigo
tratar de ser el líder idóneo para cada
uno de los equipos que me ha tocado
dirigir que lo que yo haga lo que yo
diga vea reflejado en las caras de los
muchachos que están creyendo en lo que
yo digo porque les puedo decir que este
partido lo vamos a ganar muy fácil y de
repente voltio de los movimientos como
él no corre como él nos está allá dentro
de la cancha pero si trabajamos y les
doy las herramientas para poder
conseguir hacer que las cosas se vean
fácil y que ellos hagan el trabajo fácil
seguramente estarán convencidos de que
se puede ganar y se pueden hacer muchas
cosas
muy buenas noches se pasaba un poquito
el torneo pasado el campeonato en la
fecha 11
no nos perderemos empatado un partido no
habíamos jugado muy bien y se me
acercaron los otros jugadores mi profe
lo vemos están convencidos de que
podemos ser campeones si no los repite
cada rato que vamos a hacer campeones en
la fecha 11 y afortunadamente cuando
fuimos campeones venían marchesín antes
al termina el partido y se me encadené
sea que vamos a hacer campeón yo les
vete a la portería porque no termine el
partido acá pero bueno fue parte de lo
que nos tocó vivir soy mexicano
orgullosamente mexicano que en esta
profesión y en este fútbol hay
muchísimos extranjeros que no me molesta
pero afortunadamente yo hago bien las
cosas y trato de poner el nombre de
méxico en alto y reitero soy feliz feliz
padre anáhuac y eso me da mucho gusto
muchas gracias por la invitación y
espero que le vaya muy bien gracias
gracias